all right we are taking calls via
discord at davidpakman.com
discord and uh we are doing this a
little bit earlier this week because
we are going to be off at the end of the
week due to thanksgiving
let's go next to amanda amanda who's
holding on to talk to me what's going on
amanda
amanda you're on the air what's going on
[Music]
i can hear you amanda what's going on oh
oh hello okay perfect um so i
have a question and i wanted to know
what you think about the lawsuits that
are coming
uh to trump over the next couple months
or years
once after he leaves office i think that
the most likely
um way this will go
is that trump's businesses are going to
be investigated
and this could mean anything from money
laundering
to tax evasion to everything in between
i think it's quite plausible that
trump's businesses will have to pay
some fines we've already seen you know
trump university was disbanded and had
to pay a fine
trump's charity would had to dissolve
because of its
using the money as a personal slush fund
and and i
i think that we will see that i even
think it's conceivable that there might
be
associates of the trump organization the
business
that could face criminal charges i don't
know that anybody's going to do any time
but basically i think that that's as far
as it's going to go amanda that's my
sense right now
okay and amanda is gone amanda amanda
left and that is it
from amanda that's too bad